[muffled shouting]
- HERE WE COME, SON.
HERE WE COME.
- [shouting]
HUT!
[epic theatrical music]
♪ ♪
[high-pitched tone]
[whistle blowing]
- MAN, YOU FEELING ALL RIGHT?
- YEAH, I'M FINE, MAN!
- LET'S GO, LET'S GO!
- COME ON!
- LET'S GO, MAN!
- MAN, WHAT ARE WE DOING
OUT THERE?
WHAT ARE WE DOING OUT THERE,
HUH?
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW.
NO, SERIOUSLY,
WHAT--WHAT ARE WE DOING?
- PLAYING FOOTBALL?
- OKAY, YEAH.
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, YEAH,
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, YEAH,
THAT'S IT, MAN.
PLAYING FOOTBALL, YEAH?
- YO, EXQUISITE T.
YOU NEED TO LET THE MEDICS
TAKE A LOOK AT YOU, MAN.
- DUDE, I'M ALL RIGHT, MAN.
I'M FINE.
SHOOT.
I'M HERE,
AND I'M READY TO DO THIS, MAN.
- ALL RIGHT.
- WHAT ABOUT YOU ALL, MAN?
DO YOU WANT THIS?
- YEAH.
- DO YOU WANT THIS?
all: YEAH.
all: YEAH!
- DO YOU WANT THIS?
- I MEAN, ALL YOU HAD TO DO
WAS ASK, MAN.
THERE'S PLENTY OF APPLE PIE
TO GO AROUND.
YOU WANT SOME APPLE PIE,
BROTHER?
COME ON, MAN.
WHO WANT A SLICE?
- YO, EXQUISITE T,
AIN'T NO APPLE PIE, MAN.
THAT'S YOUR HELMET.
- HEY, HEY, HEY, HEY.
DOG, DOG, DOG, MAYBE YOU SHOULD
JUST SIT OUT THE NEXT PLAY.
- SIT OUT THE NEXT PLAY?
- YEAH.
- ARE YOU GONNA SIT
OUT THE NEXT PLAY?
- NAH.
- YOU GONNA SIT
OUT THE NEXT PLAY?
I DIDN'T THINK SO.
I DON'T NEED
TO SIT OUT THE NEXT PLAY,
AND I'M GONNA TELL YOU WHY.
'CAUSE ALL Y'ALL.
'CAUSE I KNOW Y'ALL GOT MY BACK.
Y'ALL KNOW WHAT I SEE
WHEN I LOOK AT YOU?
I'MA TELL YOU WHAT I SEE.
GROWN MEN...
- YEAH, YEAH.
- WHO LOOK LIKE GIANTS...
- YEAH.
- WITH REALLY BIG SHOULDERS...
all: YEAH!
- WHO ARE WEARING SHORT PANTS.
- WHAT?
- AND JUST RIGHT THERE, A FEW
SECONDS OF COMPLETE DARKNESS,
AND THEN I SAW SOME
LITTLE FLOATY SPECKS OF LIGHT
IN THE AIR, UP LIKE THAT.
- EXQUISITE T.
- WHO IS THAT?
IS THAT CARTOON SQUIRREL
TALKING TO ME?
- YEAH!
- CARTOON SQUIRREL,
WHERE YOU AT?
- I'M HERE, MAN.
- OH, YES.
- YOU HAVE A BRAIN INJURY.
YOU NEED TO GET
SOME MEDICAL ATTENTION.
- I'M GONNA TELL YOU RIGHT NOW,
CARTOON SQUIRREL,
WHO NEEDS SOME MEDICAL ATTENTION
IS THE COUGARS OVER THERE.
- DOG, DOG, DOG.
- WHAT, WHAT?
- WE'RE PLAYING THE BRUISERS.
- RIGHT, OKAY.
- BRUISERS.
- OKAY.
LISTEN, Y'ALL.
WE NEED TO REMEMBER
WHO WE ARE, OKAY?
WE'RE THE TEAM OF DESTINY
THIS YEAR.
WE'RE THE TEAM EVERYBODY
TALKING ABOUT.
AFRAID OF, MAN.
WE GOT TO REMEMBER WHO WE ARE.
WHO ARE WE?
- RHINOS.
- WHO ARE WE?
all: THE RHINOS.
all: RHINOS!
- WHO ARE WE?
all: RHINOS.
- ARE WE THE RHINOS?
all: YEAH!
- OH, MY GOD.
SOMEBODY STOLE OUR HORNS.
WE GOT TO FIND OUR HORNS, Y'ALL.
- OH, [bleep] IT.
- WHERE THE HORNS AT?
- WHAT THE [bleep]?
[monitors beeping]